if you thought the shock of the events
of the last week would foster
a new era of cooperation in the bare pit
of american politics
you'd be wrong a resolution urging vice
president mike pence to trigger the 25th
amendment
which would remove trump from office was
blocked by the republicans
resolution calling on vice president
michael r pence to convene and mobilize
the principal officers of the executive
departments of the cabinet to activate
section 4
of the 25th amendment to declare
president donald j trump
incapable of executing the duties of his
office
an article of impeachment was quickly
introduced ratcheting up the pressure
and the resolution
makes stark reading donald trump has
demonstrated that he will remain a
threat to national security
democracy and the constitution if
allowed to remain in office
and has acted in a manner grossly
incompatible with self
governance and the rule of law
anger at the president is growing this
new videos emerged of the assault
these images show a police officer being
beaten by the mob
on the steps of america's seat of power
with president-elect joe biden's
inauguration just days away
there are fears there'll be further
violence in the days to come
the security services are concerned
right-wing extremist groups are using
social media platforms
to organize more attacks what
this president's power has exposed uh is
a
deep underbelly in the country um a a
dangerous current of white nationalism
uh that can be mobilized by people of
low ethics and without morality like
donald trump and it has been
and it's been unleashed with his account
permanently suspended
the twitter president has been keeping a
low profile
with speculation intensifying about his
state of mind
so donald trump remains silent isolated
in the white house
and with the passing of each hour more
colleagues and associates are deserting
him
in the dying light of his presidency
even to his allies
bran trump is turning increasingly toxic
but the concern for americans is the
perilous place the nation now finds
itself in
still struggling to process a seismic
event
that will shape it for years to come
president-elect
joe biden who's just received his second
dose of the covid vaccine
has much to do in the months ahead
curing america of its political sickness
whilst at the same time taming a
pandemic
which is out of control